You finished your App,
you swear you tested it thoroughly, and
now you're ready to publish, but how?
There are the obvious basics,
cleaning up the code, double checking
your servers, and building a final APK.
Once you have your final build,
you can distribute your APK through
a marketplace, like the Google Play
store, email, or on a website.
But even knowing all of this, it's
not quite clear how to get that APK.
The biggest thing here is
figuring out the difference,
between when you run your
App from Android Studio, and
when it comes from something
like the Google Play Store.
Android Studio does a good job of
hiding some of the little details
that aren't relevant to development.
For example, it automatically signs your
APK with a debug key during development.
However, you can't
publish with a debug key.
You need a separate private key,
to sign your App with,
before you can distribute
it on Google Play.
For this lesson, we've created a written
set of instructions on how to build and
sign an APK.
But, as always,
you can check the documentation link,
in the instructor notes, for more
information and details on these steps.